هذا جانب من الاحتفالات ما زالت مستمره
عقد زفاف ولي العهد الاردني الامير حسين
بن عبد الله على الانسه رجوى السيف الان
تم منحها لقب الاميره رجوى الحسين بعد ان
عقد قرانهما بحضور قاده ملوك وايضا وزراء
ورؤساء دول جاؤوا وحضروا من كافه دول
العالم هناك تنوع كبير في هذا العرس الان
بدانا نشاهد هذه الاجواء الاحتفاليه التي
ما زالت المستمره هناك فرح عارم يطغى على
المكان حاله تصفيق خصوصا في هذه
الاحتفالات في قصر زهران كان ايضا وصول
الاحتفالات ووصول العرسان الى الحسينيه
حيث استقبل الوفود وايضا الحاضرين
لمشاركتهما هذه الفرحه طبعا نتابع معكم
هذه المشاهد اليوم هو عرس عرس وطني في
كافه ارجاء المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه
الجميع يحتفل بولي العهد وبعقد قرانه على
الاميره رجوى السيف الاميره السعوديه
اليوم هذه اصبحت اميره بعد ان عقدت زفافها
وقرانها على الامير الحسين بن عبد الله
متابع معكم هذه المشاهد طبعا كنا تابعنا
ايضا وخلينا صوت الطبيعه ومن ثم نعود
[موسيقى]
الله
ما زالت هذه الاغاني الاردنيه
والاهازيج والزغاريد تطغى في المملكه
الاردنيه الهاشميه وفي هذه الاحتفالات
التي حضرها الالاف نتحدث عن اكثر من 4000
مدعو جاءوا
ليتابع ويشاركوا هذه الفرحه الفرحه ليست
فرحه اردنيه بل هي فرحه اردنيه وفرحه
سعوديه لان
الانسه رجوى الشيخ هي سعوديه والان اصبحت
الاميره رجوى الحسين
[موسيقى]
اذا كنا نتابع معكم منذ ساعات الصباح
الباكر حيث استقبل الملك عبد الله الثاني
وايضا الملكه رانيا كل الحضور منذ ساعات
الصباح الباكر ومن ثمها من ثم بعدها تم
عقد القران بحضور ايضا عدد كبير من الملوك
والقاده والامراء للدول والاحتفالات ما
زالت مستمره سواء في قصر الحسينيه وايضا
قصر زهران وحتى في شوارع المملكه الاردنيه
الهاشميه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات